a local weekly market near the town hall
and Mullen Beck vendors sell North
African products and fresh produce at
affordable prices the market used to be
a popular place to meet since last
week's terrorist attacks many people are
afraid not hold on people are avoiding
big crowds was that different a few
months ago we asked before the Paris
attacks the situation was better things
have gotten worse but is the old over
many residents feel they're being
discriminated against shabby pudgy
keisha for Belgians have a negative
image of people with Arab backgrounds
their attitude towards us has changed
for the worse we aren't alone here
journalists from all over the world have
come to see Mullen Beck for themselves
following last week's attacks so many of
the terrorists involved in Tuesday's
attack and in the Paris attack have come
from here so clearly there there is a
hotbed of Islamic extremism extremism
here how much the ordinary people who
work here and live here no I don't know
people aren't exactly happy about our
camera here at the market but at least
we can keep filming until a journalist
flies a drone over the square that is
the mood turns hostile and were forced
to leave
we waited till everyone is left and we
came back to the square and now we are
waiting for farida farid has lived in
morn bake for 35 years and she loves
this place and she even might know why
some people didn't want to have some
journalists in their neighborhood farida
Aras volunteers for a project that
provides support to disadvantaged school
children in the neighborhood she
understands why people here in
muhlenberg are angry at the media the
person's a bit noisy people who live in
molenbeek are already hugely affected
the community has become known on an
international scale because people want
to portray it as the perfect hub for
terrorism lapa fit black to not to
double his MO farida ara says that the
young people here who she calls the
children of molenbeek feel excluded
because of their origins but she's still
hopeful about the future Sid nozawa
please don't know how many these are our
children their future is here this is
their country we should open doors for
all these young people so that they can
flourish get involved in society have a
job and be well paid like everyone else
that will stop them from committing
crimes but as long as mullen back is
seen as a hotbed of terrorism it will be
difficult for people here to feel
hopeful about the future